d'ailleurs le gouvernement du québec une
nouvelle stratégie pour relancer
l'économie on avait beaucoup misé sur
l'achat local pendant la pandémie on n'a
qu'à penser au panier bleue lancée début
avril est aujourd'hui le premier
ministre françois legault va plus loin
en entrevue à la presse
il affirme vouloir augmenter la
production manufacturière et
agroalimentaire du québec
il veut même que les produits faits ici
ils remplacent de plus en plus ceux qui
sont importés on va en parler avec
geneviève dufour professeur et
codirectrice du programme en droit
international et politique
internationale à l'université de
sherbrooke
merci d'être là madame dufour le
président il des règles claires qui
encadrent le commerce international vous
les connaissez bien est ce que le
premier ministre avait le droit de faire
une sortie comme celle là ce matin je
vous dirais que c'était probablement
très légitime c'est légitime qu'un
gouvernement qu'un chef de gouvernement
veuille assurer le plein emploi surtout
après une crise ou pendant une crise
c'est normal qu'ils cherchent la
prospérité c'est normal même que il
cherchait ce qu'on devienne de plus en
plus autour suffisant avec ce qu'on a
vécu
toutefois vous l'avez dit yo direct les
règles du droit international et konami
qui proviennent soit des accords de
libre échange ou des hackers de l'om
c'est demeure applicable et le
franchement avec les déclarations
monsieur legault de ce matin pour moi il
ya des drapeaux rouges qui doivent être
levés très rapidement monsieur legault
décret ses intentions comme du
nationalisme économique en quoi ces
différentes du protectionnisme ça mais
le nationalisme économique est un
courant qui implique nécessairement une
certaine forme de protectionnisme parce
que ce qu'on veut dans nationalisme
économique s'est un peu plus
d'interventionnisme et
d'interventionnisme gouvernemental pour
assurer une certaine partie et pour
assurer une certaine autarcie faut
diminuer la concurrence étrangère et
donc nécessairement on a besoin d'être
un peu plus protectionniste il ya tout
un courant en ce moment là qu'ils
mondiales en eau les gagnants du
protectionnisme au sud du pays
mais franchement il ya un mouvement un
peu partout oui bon monsieur legault dit
l'objectif étant de réduire le déficit
commercial si on ne peut pas exporter
plus justement parce que montée du
protectionnisme américain entre autres
il va falloir réduire les importations
alors ça c'est du protectionnisme si on
freine l'entrée de produits étrangers
chez nous n'est ce pas oui tout à fait
si c'est du protectionnisme et hills
mais c'est pas tout protectionnistes qui
va à l'encontre des règles de loi ne
sait où des accords de libre-échange eux
il ya certaines formes des
gouvernementale qui peuvent être données
et donc c'est pour ça que je vous dis
pas que tout est illicite mais que je
vous dis qu'il ya des drapeaux rouges
qui doit avec le v il faut dire les
choses correctement il faut consulter il
faut s'assurer que c'est conforme au
droit
parce que sinon ce qu'on dit peut être
retenue contre eux nous après - c'est
quoi leur rêve que de fait peuvent
protéger la madame de faux mais
habituellement caillou un conflit
commercial
ça arrive pas dans la journée d'une
déclaration comme ça
si monsieur legault met en oeuvre sa
stratégie ce dont tu nous a parlé ce
matin qui a écrit plique par exemple des
exonérations fiscales pour les
entreprises qui vont produire au québec
c'est les subventions subventions qui a
priori semble est licite steam et
d'autres types de mesures en oeuvre par
exemple imposer ses ministres ses
ministères des organismes publics
d'acheter local et de ne plus respecter
les accords sur les marchés publics
dès lors on pourrait craindre que dans
quelques mois voire quelques années voir
quand gouvernement le gouffre peu au
pouvoir qui est des conflits commerciaux
qu'ils fassent en sorte que le québec le
canada va être mis en cause et les
déclarations du premier ministre
pourront être utilisés pour essayer
d'aller chercher finalement les
motivations sincère derrière des mesures
et c'est pour ça que je dis que c'est
dangereux
monsieur legault dit aujourd'hui vouloir
surtout aussi des produits québécois
entre autres dans l'agroalimentaire et
le manufacturier mais ce sont deux
secteurs pour lesquels les enjeux sont
est un peu différent en ce moment en
vertu des accords qu'on a
les enjeux sont différents et les règles
sont différentes ou six
par exemple en matière agroalimentaire
on sait que monsieur legault ce qu'il
veut c'est augmenter notre
autosuffisance n'importe quel pays peut
se défendre de vouloir être
autosuffisant afin d'assurer sa propre
sécurité
par ailleurs il le fait de manière très
intelligente en donnant entre autres des
tarifs préférentiels sur
l'hydroélectricité pour que
l'agriculture se transforme de plus en
plus en agriculture de serre et pour
qu'on puisse devenir finalement
autosuffisant tout au long de l'année et
ça c'est pour moi vrai et c'est pas
contre les règles du commerce
international
parce qu'ici on veut surtout faire en
sorte qu' on est une agroalimentation
qui soit plus écologique parce que ce
qu'on sait c'est que les subventions
hydroélectrique font en sorte qu'il ya
bien des agriculteurs qui vont laisser
aller par exemple lui le mazout des
énergies fossiles qui sont dommageables
pour l'environnement
donc c'est pas un progrès en matière
agroalimentaire moi je vois pas ça comme
un problème quand toutefois on se met à
dire que on voit tout produire au québec
on aura plus besoin d'acheter en chine
qu'on veut même financer les entreprises
qui vont première de produire au québec
là encore une fois on est dans des
subventions qui apparaissent a priori
c'est parce qu'elles sont subordonnées à
la production avec des produits locaux
mais il ya quand même moyen en vertu de
la loi il ya des façons là qu'on peut
utiliser pour créer des emplois au
québec développer la production locale
tout en respectant le droit
international
qu'est ce qu'on pourrait faire il ya
plein de façons on vient dans nos
milieux dans l'environnement
faisons en sorte que on subventionne
notre industrie pour qu'elles deviennent
de plus en plus écologique plus durable
pour assurer une transition connaître
écologique c'est possible et ça
franchement on n'est pas les gagnants la
matière il ya plusieurs états aux états
unis le maine l'état de new york tout
près de chez nous qui ont tout compris
ça par exemple monsieur legault parlait
d achat de ces ministères des organismes
publics qui était pas suffisamment local
meilleur moyen de faire une transition
écologique ans
imposant des conditions pour favoriser
les produits d'ici je comprends votre
message on va poursuivre la discussion
sûrement à l'automne quand on aura des
détails sur cette stratégie merci
beaucoup d'avoir été là madame dufour
cela me fait plaisir
bonne soirée